good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Wednesday it is hump
day the greatest day of the week well
not the greatest because like it could
be Saturday but it's a pretty good one
it's hump day don't forget to hump
someone you love and speaking of girlies
that I love and wouldn't mind gyrating
on it's Jax hey Jax how you doing
I'm darn good excited that it's hump day
excited to get over this hum incredibly
and to do it with my best friend
Lotteria
La teria so you know me I'm actually a
really good Spanish speaker and I love
that the translation of my new nickname
La turd means the turd and that's really
special to me so thank you
and it's the feminine turd and lad and
you know me I am a feminist
you are the feminine turd
so me
so you I don't I know you like every
nickname every LARP has a rhyme has a
reason every time I doubt you you always
prove me wrong
I'm so glad I could do that for you I'm
so glad to be here with you doing
another episode of the toast we have
stories the stories are story is so as
the kids would say so great when the
stories do that because they very rarely
do but this has kind of been like a busy
kind of few weeks in pop culture landia
La teria and it's great it's made for
some great episodes I know there's a lot
of drama going on with Madonna's biopic
I'm excited to talk about that
especially because we were literally
just talking about how Madonna needs a
movie like a week ago
yeah and we also in some recess of our
mind knew that there was a biopic in the
works that you know Julia Fox was
auditioning for Liz Gilly should have
been getting a card and Julia Garner had
won the part so we'll talk about that
um that breaking news breaking
extraction Read All About It
a Razzle Dazzle
um so other than that it's just you know
a typical wetness day here at the toast
um yesterday we recorded a great patreon
episode General q a with Jackson Claude
where it was just like opening up I
would say we were kind of spilling some
industry tea we cleared up a few things
um just kind of like business things
that people have been wondering about
um you know there was a lot of questions
about what went down with breaking bread
and we are divulging at all there were
also a lot of questions about what went
down with our potential new TNN podcast
with this The Scholar sisters from
Instagram everyone knows those girlies
we're spilling the two
yeah it was good yeah the tea is hot it
was low-key like a juicy episode
yeah I mean we're juicy girls aren't we
that the truth look at these cheeks
juicy juicy cheeks
um so yeah we've got a great show I
didn't really do much yesterday it was
so busy just like podcast podcast caught
podcast meeting meeting just like
endless editing we're getting literally
we're getting ready for our big
Extravaganza on Friday which we haven't
even spoken about
um so we have an episode every day this
week but our episode on Friday is going
to be very different than it has been
pre-recorded by lottery in Los Angeles
it is about like a 50 maybe 60 Minute
episode interview it's not our standard
episode it is a full interview it was
supposed to be like an extra interview
just like you know we do 20 maybe 30
minute interviews at the end when we do
have people on but I could not stop
talking to this person it was about an
hour and I just figured you know what
let it have its own moment it was that
good
yeah so that will drop on Friday yeah so
we're just editing you know like being
blogger there's a lot of hype a lot of
guesses as to who it is I've seen some
people get it like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna tell a lot either
I've seen some really good guesses and
I've seen some correct guesses I've seen
some wishful thinking guesses I love
that people I'm like we have such a good
guest coming on and they're like Kylie
Elon it's like so nice calm down
um it's nice like you think I would not
be there for Eli right no but you think
like we could or Kylie we could get
those people it's so nice when people
like guess above our pay grade you know
yeah but some people like are just they
wake up one morning they're like I want
to do a podcast and then they turn to
their assistant and they're like what do
you listen to and then it's like
whatever that assistant listens to is
what they're gonna go on it's so true
the power that celebrity assistants have
is not lost on me and I actually know
what we have a quite a few even Friday's
guests really only knew about the toast
from his assistant who came
right so any celebrity assistants out
there just like wait until your celeb
wakes up and asks like what podcast
should I go on and please offer up the
toast it's so true the power that lies
within a celebrity assistant cannot be
underestimated
but only if it's a celebrity you think
we want on oh yeah
you know because we're really choosy
yeah no and I feel like people ask me
like all the time about um like who's
the best guest and who do you want to
have and I really can't stress enough
how we're not an interview show and I
think there's so many interview shows
out there that are so great and if we
get someone amazing it's great but I
think a lot of people's like numbers
depend on who the guest is going to be
and I really like that we have like this
stable routine I think people love an
episode just as much when it's just us
two and it's not like an episode with a
guest we'll get double the amount as a
regular episode like we have a really
strong base and I actually really like
that I think it's good for business and
it's just like it's a lot of pressure
when you're an interview show like every
single episode to like top the next one
and keep getting people of that caliber
I think it could be you know kind of
draining
yeah so if your celeb is someone that
you know that like we love and it's
interesting we want to talk to them and
they are looking to go on a podcast like
feel free to recommend yarker yeah if
Kiki Palmer's assistant is out there
holler at your girl
yes exactly so we've got a great show
not much to catch up on how are you how
are things how is rolled most
importantly
things are really good
um not much to share I've been going to
sleep really early so like not I didn't
start my movie watching though I thought
about it but I knew I'd be up too late
and I've just been really tired so I'm
gonna wait like maybe till the weekend
but I am going to be doing my movie
Extravaganza also I want to remind
everyone that the new episode of the
redheads drops next week we haven't
recorded it I haven't even started the
book the book is a Jackie's Choice it's
the
The Many Lives of Marjorie post some
[__] like that and the reviews from the
redheads who are already reading it the
fans they're loving it they said it's
like the jackiest choice of all time
they're learning so much it's one of
these books that like you're on Google
half the time and the Magnus the
Magnificent lives of Marjorie post and I
think it's a great time to become a
redhead so I just wanted to throw that
out there and if you read the book now
then you can get in some questions and
we'll answer them on the show it's just
a great Community I love that I'm so
glad that it's been a while since I
reminded you guys since it's January
people have their resolutions like if
you wanted to read more books but like
you haven't read one yet like make it
this one why not why not you and why not
okay let's do like a little circle back
on our resolutions what were our
resolutions and are we keeping up with
them I'm definitely not keeping up with
my dressing like a [__] I am clearly
wearing sweatshirt and sweatpants today
and even when I go out I'm not even
looking remotely hoary so I need to I
need to work on that
okay but you're still saying I'm still
saying yes and I do feel like I've
stopped a lot of my negative self-talk
I'm trying to like it's in my brain as
actively trying to stop but you know
what sometimes it's funny
yeah
I didn't have that many resolutions I
think one was just to not consume
content that is not good for my mental
health so it's either content upper or
something that I'm learning education
something educational so even though
Dope Sick wasn't a Content upper I
learned so much that's good
um and I I've stuck to that really I
haven't watched a piece of crap good
okay so we're all keeping up on our
resolutions this is your you know one
month in reminder
you got to keep them up all Year guys
not just the first week but I feel like
when I start watching these Oscar movies
it's going to conflict with my
resolution because it's going to be crap
yeah and then it's like do I turn it off
in the middle like what if I had to pay
money to rent yeah no that's the thing
with like popular not popular but like
critically acclaimed movies and TV shows
like they have to make you depressed in
order to be critically acclaimed it's so
dumb
yeah like you didn't see the greatest
showman getting the China deserved why
because like we weren't miserable I
think that's why though Ted lasso was
such like a cultural phenomenon because
like it was getting that critical
Acclaim but the whole point of the show
was to spread joy and it's all about
like kindness and and it's nice
yeah that was good we didn't do season
that's been a really long time it's
coming soon I saw I've been seeing some
stuff online like I don't we don't have
a date yet but like they're starting to
roll out it's it's too long the news
it's a year I feel like it's more
okay
that's just how I feel
well you're entitled to your feeling
because I feel like and if correct me if
I'm wrong a year ago at the last Golden
Globes was when Jason Sudeikis won
and the season had come out before that
yeah so it's been more than a year
okay
just and now you know that I'm just a
stickler for data
ain't that the truth who isn't though no
one no one I wanna so I think without
further Ado let's not you know beat
around the bush if you will let's Dive
In
okay without further uh do here are the
past five stories that you yeah you you
need to know today's episode is brought
to you by Tommy John is it weird to give
underwear for a gift on Valentine's Day
no but it is weird to give bad or ugly
underwear on Valentine's Day so pamper
your partners posterior with Tommy John
when you and your favorite person are
wearing Tommy John you're that much more
comfortable so you can do everything
better Tommy John's incredibly soft
breathable underwear can play make a
playful Valentine's Day gift for pajamas
limited editions ninety percent of men
and women love Valentine's Day gifts
from Tommy John thanks to dozens of
comfort innovators like soft Tri Blends
and micro modal Fabrics with four-way
stretch Tommy John helps you feel the
love all year long I have like a pair of
Tommy jump pajamas that have just
changed my life like I've had them for a
few months now they're super cute
they're blue long sleeve pants but the
Comfort level is next level and I try to
stay away from long sleeves sometimes
because I get really hot in my sleep but
the fabric is so thin but so soft I find
myself reaching for these pajamas more
than my short sleeve or my shorts ones
like it's really a premium product
because with me and pajamas the cream
Rises like I'll know which ones I like
the best because I'm wearing them day
after day night after night Tommy John
is really good also just perfect time of
year Valentine's Day is coming up
um I'd love to gift Ben like sexy little
intimate things you know like maybe I'll
buy myself something but like it's for
Ben because it's Valentine's Day you
know what I mean because it's like you
get to sleep next to this goddess in
Tommy John
yeah Tommy John just doesn't just have
customers they have Fanatics with over
20 million pairs sold it's easy to see
why get 20 off your first purchase at
tommyjohn.com toast right now for
Valentine's Day that's tommyjohn.com
toast for 20 off tommyjohn.com toast see
site for details today's episode is also
brought to you by Perfect bar if you're
looking for a protein bar that actually
that actually tastes good well look no
further than the perfect bar with their
lineup of fresh from the fridge protein
bars perfect bar is exactly what you've
been looking for no chalky artificial
aftertaste here if you're looking for
nutritious and delicious snack look no
further whether your New Year's
resolution was to you know start
snacking better or you're just hungry
and looking for a good snack protein the
perfect bar protein bars are for you
they're made with freshly ground nut
butter organic honey and 20 organic
superfoods they have a variety of
products like protein bars and little
snack size bars that are so good and
good for you a personal favorite of mine
is the dark chocolate chip peanut butter
it has a little sea salt on it which is
really chef's kiss I love that you keep
them in the fridge that's how you know
the ingredients are like really fresh
not super processed fresh to death to
death it just like kind of makes a lot
of sense when you think about it and
then you look at other protein bars that
are not and you're like ew
um so the little snack sizes they have
to are fabulous for like a long day
travel take it from the fridge throw it
in your purse it stays good all day and
you are going to feel full those little
snack sizes have six grams of proteins
and 150 calories so a little goes a long
way
yes the perfect bar knows that it'll be
Love At First Bite so for a limited time
they're offering you a chance to try
their refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text or upload and upload a picture of
your receipt from your local grocery
store and they will reimburse you for
the cost of one bar it'll go directly
into your venmo or your PayPal which is
pretty cool it's pretty cool all you
have to do is go to perfect snacks.com
toast get that free perfect bar today
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
bar today
thank you McLaren we are welcome
our first story some really surprising
baby news Paris Hilton is a mom she
reveals that she and her husband Carter
room have welcomed a baby boy the
businesswoman and media personality
Paris Hilton and her husband recently
welcomed their first baby together a son
via surrogate People magazine can
confirm uh Paris told people exclusively
quote it's always been my dream to be a
mother and I'm so happy that Carter and
I found each other we are so excited to
start our family together and our hearts
are exploding with love for our baby boy
she shared the news on Instagram a photo
of her gripping the baby's hand and she
wrote you were already loved beyond
words I feel like everyone in America is
so happy for Paris Hilton right now like
it's because I feel like in a way like
especially Our Generation we feel like
we grew up with her and we saw her like
through hard times and good times and
then with her documentary and we just
like have learned a lot about her in
recent years on a personal level
um we know how much she went through and
how much she really wanted to be a mom
like in her documentary when she was
playing with her nieces and nephews and
she was just talking about how like this
is like all she wants which was
surprising I wouldn't have thought that
I was so happy to see this and it
reminds me of like a little while ago
there was a story going around that she
was pregnant
yeah well like there was a story going
around that she was pregnant but also
that she had started like iaf which was
true and uh because they did IVF to like
get the eggs and the embryos too because
she the baby came via surrogate
um but Kathy Hilton had said like a few
months ago I think she like misspoke
that Paris was starting like treatment
like IVF stuff in the new year or
something like that and Paris was like
no I'm not but I think both of them were
telling the truth because Paris wasn't
starting it but it had been started the
surgery surrogate was pregnant yeah yeah
so it's just interesting now to look
back on that like that was true I love
that she still like we all believed her
and there was really no speculation and
she probably like she probably got to go
through this process like really
secretly and privately and that's
probably really nice
um and I'm just so happy like I can't
wait to see Paris as a mom she's not
gonna be like other moms no she won't be
but I'm really excited to see her as a
mom too and I'm so happy for her
especially like when it's something that
you've wanted for so long yeah and I
feel like she tried to find love so many
times she was like a hopeless romantic
with like being engaged and and she
really really is like a fairy tale
ending this whole thing she got herself
a business bambo Carter and it's great
yeah businessman and that's why it
always works out with a business member
it does good things come from a
businessman boat good things come to
those who business
and now she had a boy which is surprised
because she's so yeah she had a boy oh I
don't know why I didn't see her she's
just like so girly
um
I guess you could say the same for me I
wonder what she's gonna what she named
I'm also curious because I do believe
when you do IVF surrogate you can choose
the gender you can choose but you don't
have to right so either she let like the
fates handle it or she chose a boy which
I couldn't see you're right she's so
girly maybe Carter really wanted a boy
I feel like she let the fates handle it
I don't know why I feel that way I just
no she's like a spiritual girly 11 11
make a wish
right right so like let the chips fall
where they met yeah but I still like I'm
so looking forward to like the content
and the outfits she's gonna be hilarious
and she's I'm I'm really so happy for
her and I feel like everyone is
yeah what do you think the name is going
to be like what's the vibe do you think
she's gonna go traditional
I I could definitely think it's going to
be like a really celebrity kind of I
could see her like giving a name that's
also the name of a town like Paris you
know like yes I was saying that too like
York I don't know like like Denver okay
that's like kind of cool but like Paris
is like Global and international so like
Austin oh but you're thinking America
like let's think big globally okay you
know what's do you ever watch the show
Money Heist no
all of they're like grabbing a bank
whatever and all of the robbers they
have nickname they they call each other
names they're all named after six
so like there's Tokyo and like you
really start to see these names as
people people
so there's Moscow
who else Rio Rio's Q
Rio is cute I don't know I'm so curious
or it'll be like something so Paris like
twinkle I don't know
or it'll be like Max Ben
Maximilian Maximilian Hilton room
I like it I like it too Maximilian
and every time you say it you have to do
jazz hands
I'm so happy that's my official
prediction
official prediction not to make
everything about me I think like a lot
of people when they saw this news we're
curious like did Claudia know she
empowers her so close I did not
you didn't have this as I thought
maybe but I feel like she didn't even
tell her like the closest people to her
like no I really feel like she kept it
very tight-lipped I saw her literally
two weeks ago and you never would have
known
yeah that's awesome yeah I'm so happy
for her
I wonder when the baby was born could
have been yeah so true
you know yeah
so congratulations baby Max welcome to
the world so cute
so cute okay are you ready for our next
story
some great news some sports news
what did you think it was going to
becomes performing at the Grammys
no the same but this okay and Chris
Stapleton will be singing the National
Anthem at the Super Bowl oh that's good
I didn't even see that yep yep I know
Zach sent it to me and otherwise I would
not have seen it not Chris Stapleton not
getting the respect he deserves
but he will when he sings his people are
going to be shocked you know everyone
who thinks they know [__] about [__]
when it comes to Country like oh it's
just a bunch of people drinking about
beer like you are gonna plots when you
hear the vocal range of this man and you
know what I can't even picture him
singing the National Anthem because it's
such like a balloty I'm so I've I'm so
looking forward to the Super Bowl
yeah I look like I'm about to sing the
nationality
maybe I should be singing I love this
choice I love this choice
I love this choice and in recent years
it's been a country star who's been
singing the National Anthem like last
year it was Mickey Guyton I don't know
who remember who it was the year before
that the year we went to the Super Bowl
it was pink and it was so beautiful and
pink has not done a halftime show
correct not yet it's a big mistake comma
huge
yeah but it's good to have people who
are
would be eligible you know what I mean
like we always need to pull from that
list there's not that many no it's true
like the Evergreen list of people who
haven't done it but could pink Kelly
Clarkson Rihanna was on that list for a
while Taylor Swift
um
Carrie Underwood Carrie Underwood
yeah
yeah but who's like an apple music
person because that's who's the sponsor
now
I feel like they're all Apple music yeah
whatever I'm like so thrilled with this
choice I can't believe I didn't even see
it posted anywhere like any Outlets
talking about this this is awesome I
love this choice
yes also Babyface will be performing
America the Beautiful also gorgeous
beautiful song and when I think of
Babyface what do you think of
literally like because I was I think I
was like a little too young to be
familiar with the music of Babyface but
thanks to the Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills when David and Yolanda threw like
this really show-offy gaudy dinner party
and had Babyface sit down at the piano
and play his tune for everyone now I'm
extremely familiar with his work
yes and then Cheryl Lee Ralph from
Abbott Elementary will be performing the
hymn lift every voice and sing Oh you
know she has a nice voice I don't know
if you remember when she won an Emmy or
something last year she sang For Her
speech and it was like really powerful
does she sing in the show I only watch
the first season but no
it doesn't seem like a show it's like a
scene but she's like a really talented
person like she's known for acting but
she's also like kind of like Cynthia
like Chrissy like Cynthia Revo like a
unbelievable actress who also has like
the voice of a generation Chrissy Metz
yes
Claudia ashrae
Jackie yeah sure sure
Jackie sure he's getting worse and worse
sure sure no I know it's really
unfortunate it is but it gives you such
like a
like a uniqueness to your character like
obviously I think when you become a mom
you start singing more than ever and
yeah would it be nice for Harry to have
somebody who could carry a tune sure but
that's why he is me and for you like
it's just it's so uniquely you like
Harry will get older and be like yeah I
know that bitch's voice anywhere
yeah nice
yeah
so that's exciting the entertainment
lineup is stacked and I you know that
like this weekend are the championship
games for the AFC and the NFC so it's
down to four whoever wins these games
this weekend goes I'm telling you I
would be so sad if a 49ers don't win
like obviously I think the 49ers will be
sad but like I will be sad too
so as you know because you're probably
going to Philly like the eagles are
playing the 49ers and then the chiefs of
Kansas City are playing the Bingo right
and that game's really interesting
because it's like QB versus QB like the
Bengals QB is that guy Joe burrow who is
so [__] hot like you never saw a man
so handsome in your goddamn life and
then it's the Mahomes of it all Jackson
Brittany like of course we know
yeah
um and it's like who do you think's
gonna win like I think the Chiefs
they're really strong but the Bengals
were in the Super Bowl last year so like
they're really strong too I I personally
am rooting for the Bengals because I
really like that guy Joe burrow like I I
like what he's got going on when it
comes to his face and his body and I
think it's it's really good powerful
stuff
well if Kansas City wins and then of
course the 49ers will win actually don't
let me say that because I am a genius I
am a bad I'm a curse no by the way she's
her favorite it's kind of like coasted a
little bit
with the teams they play like the eagles
are extremely good like extremely okay
but if if it's the 49ers versus the
Chiefs like we had that Super Bowl a few
years ago so it's a rematch that's cool
I like that yeah and you know what it
wasn't the 49ers time as we predicted
many years ago we knew it but I feel as
though now more than is ever it's their
time
I agree and I just have to say like if
it winds up being Eagles versus the
Bengals like I'm not even watching oh I
don't know either of them like I'm
calving in early no but like Joe burrow
like I would I would tune in especially
for the entertainment now that I know
Chris Stapleton right right right right
I'll be commercials I'll be there
through till halftime yeah it's always
also fun to see what celebrities Go I
mean last year when I was in L.A it was
star-studded this is in Arizona which is
still like a pretty cool destination I
think so
um if the 49ers are in the Super Bowl
like I am going to try and go
and I love love Arizona and so does Ben
because it's like a golfer's Paradise
but I don't know why I didn't do a stop
there this year it was just kind of it's
a kind of remote like it's so far and
there's really not a bunch of tour
spaces around it for me
um but I did like six shows in Tucson
Phoenix Scottsdale Scottsdale I went
back like two three times on the djt
it's one of the best cities like it's so
fun
yeah so that's cool if you go yeah I
really like I'm hoping the 49ers win
obviously because you know I want the
players and their family to achieve you
know a Super Bowl but personally like I
want to go because
I want them to win because I want to go
you want them to win because you want to
go yeah like for me yeah
confirmed agreed so a little Sports Talk
uh
uh yes see at the big game see the big
game this weekend guys
oh whoa next story a little nepo baby
name is Kaya Gerber is on the cover of L
magazine and she's doing a wide-ranging
interview though her quotes about being
a nepo baby are the ones that are
getting the most play
um and when read out of context you know
they are a little out of touch but I did
myself a favor and I read the whole
interview good for you as I wanted I
wanted to get a better sense of the girl
yeah and you know she's really like
she has a really good head on her
shoulder okay and I felt like in re like
the nepo stuff is at the bottom and by
the time I got there like I had a pretty
good idea high opinion of her so I
wasn't coming at it from like a this
wedge piece spoiled brat
but she you know here's the quote
she said uh the interviewer asked in
modeling and also in the celebrity world
in general there's a lot of conversation
lately about people having an easier
time getting into the industry because
of a family member do people sometimes
make make assumptions about how you got
here also it's important to note we know
Kaya Gerber as a model but she has two
acting projects coming out she's now
like doing some at home and her she said
for those who don't know is Cindy
Crawford and her dad is Randy Gerber uh
one of the founders of casimigo's
tequila very very successful
well-connected businessman yeah they are
like she's like the actual definition of
an apple baby like if you if you looked
it up in a dictionary it would be her
face more so I think than anyone because
also like her talent in modeling like is
a result of negative she got it from her
parents it's genetic
yeah she said I won't deny the privilege
that I have even if it's just the fact
that I have a really great source of
information and someone to give me great
advice that alone I feel very fortunate
for that's it I think that's a strong
point that is a privilege to have like a
like by the way for sure people that you
can go to and ask for sure but that's
like one of like yeah yeah that's like
and that's like the least in like
relevant one like the knowledge to help
you book The gigs your name I thought
that was for sure I thought that was a
good spin on it though what I think that
there's really no way a nepo baby can be
asked about being an apple baby without
us all collectively rolling our eyes and
for the most part like this isn't the
worst one that I've seen I wait there's
more there's more she said my mom always
joked quote if I could call and book a
Chanel campaign it would be for me and
not for you but I also have met with
amazing people through my mom whom I now
get to work with she said with acting so
she's it's she's like acknowledging the
modeling privilege she said with acting
it's so different no artist is going to
sacrifice their vision for someone's kid
that just isn't how art is made and what
I'm interested in is Art also no one
wants to work with someone who's
annoying and not easy to work with and
not kind yes nepotism is prevalent but I
think if it was actually what people
make it out to be we'd see even more of
it I think that last line is what's
rubbing people the wrong way because
like how could we see more nepotism
every single
unless they were like discovered at the
moment it's so important that we're
taught that we remember we're talking
about acting which is really not like
the most difficult thing to master like
it's not like a rocket scientist son
wants to you know get on board the
rocket and he doesn't know like it's not
hard to pick up acting I feel as though
normal people act in their everyday
lives you know I'm acting like I'm
having fun at this party I say hi to the
door how are you and it's like you're
acting it's your outside face like
acting is not so serious I think a lot
of people when they talk about art like
they get so in their own like [__]
they like start believing it's like well
you know you need to have the talent for
sure but like it's not juggling it's
acting it's really not that hard
plus I think with
um a lot of movies directors whatever
like there's two pieces to it there's
the art and then there's also like the
commercial success and casting someone
who is going to like you know who has a
name already and a famous last name is
definitely going to bring more
commercial success and interest than a
nobody she didn't say anything that bad
I just think there's really never going
to be like amazing reception to a nepo
baby speaking on nepo babies I will say
though Andy Cohen asked Allison Williams
who's doing like a ton of press right
now because of that movie Megan that
movie looks good it looks like this book
we read for the redheads Clara and it
looks funny
um and he just asked her Point Blank and
I will say it was probably the best
answer I've seen because she is so
quintessential like woke up one day
Brian Williams daughter got on the
biggest TV show at the time without ever
having acted
all of them and she was like no like
it's so real like I literally decided to
do this I did it very quickly she's she
made the analogy like a baseball like
she was like I started my career on
third base
yeah and it and you know what it's
amazing and I'm very grateful and I
still and it doesn't take away from the
fact that I work really hard and she
does she's like very talented
um but two things can be true at the
same time that was probably the best and
most honest just like unreal like just
calm down it's not that serious like she
was very casual about it and it was a
very good response
yeah that is good also like I think this
what Kai is saying about like you know
acting can be same can be said for
modeling like a fashion designer that's
their art they're not just gonna put
like some kid in it no and there's more
to acting I mean there's more to
modeling than just standing there like
it's actually low-key hard to be a model
like posing into walking but overall I
thought she gave a pretty good interview
the pictures are gorgeous and so is she
it's crazy that she's only 21. I know
and I feel like she's been around
forever and she's like I know it's like
she hasn't even starved you know and I
feel like she Rose to fame like really
quietly she doesn't she's not thirsty
she doesn't do a lot of press she's had
like some really cool celebrity
relationships but like very quickly she
just went from being like Cindy
Crawford's pretty daughter to being like
a face of Chanel and like walking in the
most premium Milan Paris fashion week
and she did it all like quietly
yeah yeah also something else that
bothered me is though so she's on the
cover of L and like the sub header is
like Kaya Gerber has main character
energy oh my God and I just feel like
that's so cringe it's cringe when like L
which is supposed to be this like
Pinnacle of fashion and journalism and
literacy is using dumb quotes from Tick
Tock that's like an attempt yeah that's
not like a hot take like Kaya Gerber has
made like nobody thought she was the
supporting wait so they think that Kaia
Gerber daughter of the world's most
famous model and a
multi-multi-millionaire
girlfriend of Elvis is absolutely
gorgeous and perfect looking and slim
and radiant they think she has main
character energy I don't know if I see
that
I don't know if I agree
duh [__] morons
I'm so glad you brought that up because
that's [__] dumb
yeah and now it's like on the cover for
like it lives in perpetuity
yeah like there's this coffee table book
of like Vogue covers and this one will
be on it and it's like if there was a
book of albums like you'd be in 50 years
looking back and like she has no camera
in 15 years they would look back on us
and be like they were not okay in 2023
well they will be saying that regardless
so you know what it's essentially times
lean in leave enough of a trail for
future Generations
it's a cry for help
yeah it is not okay
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
manscaped breaking news alert alert our
friends at manscape are now selling
beard products just in time for
Valentine's Day that's right the leader
in men's below the waist grooming are
once again revolutionizing the men's
hygiene game with the new beard hedger
Pro kit no one likes a weird beard so
say goodbye to all your stubble trouble
and tame his main this Valentine's Day
and of course save 20 off and free
shipping by going to manscape.com and
using Code toast so the beard hedger Pro
kit is Ultimate Valentine's Day gift
because you will be happy with it too
the electric beard hair trimmer which is
the beard hedger is a premium beard
sculpting machine it's a cordless
trimmer it has a rotary rotary oh my God
rotary wheel with 20 haircut cutting
lengths all with one guard so there's no
more messy draw full of extra dumb
things you have to clip onto the razor
those things drive me nuts
plus it's waterproof you could shave in
the shower and avoid all the hair around
your sink okay
just gets better and better they also
have um in the kit for four
dermatologist tested formulations for
his post trim hygiene there's a beard
shampoo and conditioner a beard oil and
a beard balm it comes with three gifts
so also a beard brush a comb and
scissors to ensure that you have all the
tools that your men needs for the
perfect beard you're going to love it so
is he but most importantly you get 20
off in free shipping when you use code
toast at manscaped.com that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscaped.com use
code toast the manscaped beard hedger
one stroke one guard 20 lengths code
toast
um that is actually like one of the best
Valentine's Day gifts you could get for
your man because it really it will make
your life easier like it being
waterproof like let's not
yeah this episode is filled with
Valentine's Day gifts yeah we were just
getting asked that on the patreon if we
had any good Valentine's Day gifts idea
and we said mans get we literally said
man and Tommy John code toast after
giving a very philosophical answer about
how gifts don't matter yeah but they do
yeah yeah they do and it's like an easy
way to get a gift for your man and it's
for you and like it looks like you
really like you really tried
yeah also I wanted to back up to one
more thing from the interview because
apparently Kyogre like had a virtual
book club at one point and then the
interviewer was saying how like
apparently there's a celebrity book
stylist who will choose books for
celebrities to like walk around holding
to make them look impressive like
whatever Vibe they want to put forth
they like haven't read the book they can
read the book if they want but like it
like curates what what kind of books
should be in like their Instagram photo
like what are we wanting to show people
that we're reading how [__] crazy is
that that's diabolical just read
yeah
I'm shook to the [__] core by
that information
I thought that was a really fun fact
extremely fun Kai Kyle was shook by that
too because she does read a lot she I
feel like she would like I get the vibe
from her but maybe it's just because
she's been styled to make me think that
no she she was shook to hear this
information well I mean that's literally
that's so [__] fraudulent it's next
level like I can't
yeah wow yeah
okay our next story Madonna biopic
starring Julia Garner has been scrapped
as Madonna embarks on her world tour
the anticipated biopic of music legend
Madonna is taking indefinite holiday the
project which the icon was going to
direct herself is no longer in
development at Universal Pictures
multiple sources told variety
speculation over the fate of the movie
began instantly after Madonna announced
a career spanning World Tour last week
insiders familiar with Madonna said her
sole focus is the tour but she remains
committed to making a film about her
life one day
um
so Madonna had said about writing this
movie that like you know a lot of movies
have been written about her but none of
them have been good because they've all
been written by men or directed by men
and so like now she was going to take on
the job of like producing directing this
movie but now that she's going on World
Tour she can't Julia Garner was slated
to star in the role after what has been
hailed as like Madonna boot camp like
apparently the audition process was
extremely grueling singing dancing
choreography Julia Garner you know she
got the job a million girls would kill
for and now it's not a job anymore
there's also like whisper so I guess a
few like Madonna recently signed a big
contract with Warner Music Group
so maybe when the project is ready to
happen it will be with Warner Brothers
yeah Studios well I mean I think from a
business perspective
she's gonna generate way more Revenue
doing a tour than she would a movie of
course a tour is so much more work um
but if she's gonna spend the next year
working on a project it'll be one
that'll make her a couple hundred
million dollars as opposed to a movie
that honestly sounds like it's like not
like she's directing her own movie like
it sounds slow budget like
like I think that she should be a
liaison to the movie you know the one
that the Presleys were to Elvis you know
the way that Pamela Anderson was not
right to Pam and Tommy and I don't know
if you've been seeing a lot of the press
that she's been doing and she's a
documentary out now but like it's
traumatized yeah for her yeah to relive
it I think Madonna should be involved
but also I kind of feel like if they
tell the story in the way that we see it
she had this huge career and now she's
had a couple years of floundering but
she's about to go on a world tour like
maybe this is the end of the movie where
it's like
you know how amazing this tour was and
it could bring back her career and like
make all this money and you know it's it
would be a very happy ending movie
whereas if it the movie ended right now
Jackie I don't think Madonna sees the
last few years how we see that no no I
don't think it's it's intentional I'm
just saying I think it will make a
better movie story yeah I guess how do
you really
um
I guess we'd have to look at the Elton
John like how do you end a movie
about someone who's still alive you know
yeah it's just like they found happiness
with Elton John like he got sober he's
married and he's like he found peace
right and he's like officially like you
know cemented in the Music Hall of Fame
yeah like Legends so was Madonna I guess
so
I feel like they can't see it yet but
zooming out like this period of last 10
years maybe is just like a little bit of
what's next and then this world tour
she's back tickets sold out in minutes
you know right she's top of her game it
reminds me of um hacks yeah you know
with yes comedy special I mean
I like I'm glad she's involved but like
movies need directors and directing is
actually not something you could just
decide to do one day like acting sorry I
said it uh directing like I feel like
you need to know a lot about like
cinematography and just like the film
industry so like a film that you know
has a
big major star like Julia Gardner being
directed by like a first-time director I
don't know it sounds like it wouldn't
have even been good this is probably for
the best
no I think there were other people
working on the project like Diablo Cody
took a stab at an earlier version of the
script no I'm saying the film needs a
director
yeah
Can it have more than one director
though like I feel like she'd be a
director no that's what they say
producer
everyone who like sets foot on a set and
has like a little bit of money is called
a producer
yeah if you're like a little bit more
involved you're an executive producer
but a director is a director like it's
the films
yeah they're the one who picks up the
award right wins and makes sense maybe
there can be two sure like the Cohen
Brothers I feel like they're a directing
Duo
okay yeah but it sounds like it was just
Madonna and honestly like you you can't
yeah there's no other director names you
can't just decide to direct
but maybe she has a history of direction
of like music videos
maybe she has Madonna directed before
I'm sure she's directed some of her
music videos like that's what a lot of
major Stars start to do like Taylor
Swift
yeah and then they become director yeah
has Madonna directed a movie
nothing of no okay so like I said
well are you ready for our fifth and
final story it's a little more content
news that is Julia Garner adjacent
ex-convict Anna Sorkin will film a
reality series called delvey's Dinner
Club during her house arrest she's also
throwing a birthday party I saw a bunch
of influencers talking about it in one
of my group chats
inventing Anna was just the start and
Adele V sarkin has landed her own
unscripted series delvey's Dinner Club
set to be filmed inside her New York
City East Village Apartment where she's
currently serving house arrest the
series comes from Courtney White and
butternut uh sarkin who was released
from Ice in October 2022.oken
okay wants to tell her story in the new
show she'll do it through what's already
been become one of the hottest tables in
town Invitation Only intimate dinners at
her home per the press release there
adelvy invited group of actors musicians
Founders socialites journalists and
other esteemed guests will join her each
week around a private Chef cater table
replete with candid conversations where
no topic is offline it's literally aunt
is
it's literally her Club I feel like
based on the description of the people
attending like you could get an
interview I was literally thinking the
same thing but honestly I find this news
to be like really dumb [__] no [__]
like this woman is like not a good
person like already we've like
glamorized her story now she's like
getting a platform to like I don't do
what now like what what about her makes
people think she has something to say
that like we want to hear like she's a
queen no it's so true like the way we
are the way we're so obsessed with like
certain stories to the point where we
glamorize them to the level where we do
we literally forget common sense like
this is a con woman who stole money and
I know nobody cares because she's still
from Banks but she like ruined several
people's lives she stole from her
friends yeah she's a con woman and it's
like it's not funny to like glamorize it
even though if I was invited I totally
would go
I know but like
I have no interest in watching this
person this sounds like one of those
shows like gets a pilot they announce TV
shows all the time that absolutely never
come to fruition and I feel like this
might be one of them
really it's in like variety that happens
all the time
like if it's not good variety Hollywood
Reporter they write like just industry
news when like a network will pick up a
pilot or something but that doesn't mean
that the show is ever going to be made
for the for the masses
yeah I could see this drink like a vice
web series
I just think it's so weird like what we
obsess over they are like obsess over
and platform and it's like this is not a
good person this is not my plate I
completely and it's not like she was
famous before like she's famous for
being a con woman
like I don't think that people need to
be like hearing from her zero lies were
inspired and inspired by her and like
you know when you're someone with your
own TV show Dallas dinner party like
that's like you know
you look at someone they got like a role
model like
having interesting conversations of
course like that concept of like Supper
Club we're gonna have interesting
disruptors come for dinner it's first of
all not an original idea and second of
all she's not a disrupter she's a
criminal
yeah and also a bunch of like Hawaii 20
people sitting around the table like
talking
conversations sounds [__] dress no
it's also so out of touching we are in
economic turmoil people are losing their
job right with a private Chef in house
arrest like I'm sorry like this is a bad
idea for all the people where are all
the people who are upset about Colleen
Hoover's coloring right to like applied
lens to something like this no that's so
[__] weird
but um those are my thoughts those are
pretty good thoughts I agree
that's our show
what about oh my God I forgot it's
Wednesday
dear toasters but it's okay we'll do it
tomorrow yeah oh my God I totally
because we have to select them because I
have to select them and I don't have the
email on my new iPad the iPad three
throw Loop I'm so sorry you guys I will
choose them right after this and I'll
make them really good and you know what
maybe if you were wanting to write in
this is your sign we didn't read it
today but we are tomorrow but if you
submit now you'll be at the top of the
end you'll be at the top of the index
submit now dear toasters gmail.com our
weekly advice segment that we usually do
on Wednesdays but I had a major brain
fart today I'm so sorry
we'll do it tomorrow Now's the Time dear
toasters gmail.com I'm so sorry Jacqui
that's okay she's human human I know it
seems like she's not because she's
literally perfect slays everything she
does but she is
she's only human and I do I bleed when I
fall down
thanks I guess that's it right I'm so
sorry
that's okay yeah that's our show thank
you guys so much for listening to the
toast the millennial Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found on
Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio
iHeartRadio castbox all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the toast and leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are hope you guys have an increase
talented Wednesday don't forget to help
someone you love them we'll see you
tomorrow
love ya bye